[музика]
класна іграшка це я зробила Мене звати
Настя і я столярка
я приходжу на роботу о 9:00 у першій
половині дня я працюю з деревом а далі
малюю ескі за меблів та готую собі
роботу на наступний день за станком
працює найбільше 5 годин бо далі
концентрація знижується найбільше люблю
майструвати з дуба Він має особливу
текстуру і запах хоча порода досить
примхлива
у процесі роботи забуваю що відбувається
навкруги увага тільки на майбутню
іграшку Напевно це в мене така медитація
звичайно щоб бути столяром потрібно
багато знати як працювати на станках і
зубилами потрібно відчувати породу
дерева Але всьому можна навчитися Якщо є
бажання працювати
батьки мене готували до вступу у виш
добре що я вчасно зрозуміла що маю
обрати інший шлях Повірте переконати
батьків було непросто але врешті після
дев'ятого класу Я вступила в училище на
столяра дуже рада що змогла почути себе
і дякую батькам що зараз вірять і
підтримують вже під час навчання я
намалювала свої перші ескізи іграшок і
ми з моїми одногрупниками почали разом
працювати в нас вийшло зараз маємо
власну невеличку майстерню ви знаєте Я
відчуваю себе тут корисною світ не
зупинився діти мають мати дитинство
завдяки нам все працює як треба